the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic hello out there everybody
listening to the into the impossible
podcast the production of the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination
I am your fearful host than these
fearful times Bryan Keating and today
I'm joined with a friend and fellow
astrophysicist dr. Mario Livio who is
the author of many books we're going to
talk about his newest book in particular
which is called Galileo and the science
deniers I want to give a quick bio of
dr. Livio who is known for many many
books but he's also known as an
internationally famous and renowned
astrophysicist he's a best-selling
author and popular speaker who worked
for 24 years with the Hubble Space
Telescope he's a fellow of the American
Association for the Advancement of
science has written six previous books
to this one in Galileo and more than 400
scientific articles he's appeared on 60
minutes Nova and even The Daily Show and
he's lectured all around the world
literally including here in San Diego
and we'll get back to that in a little
bit and he has a very widely watched
TEDx talk called TEDx mid-atlantic which
was associated with one of his books
from I think it was 28th 2012 when I saw
that video he lives in Baltimore
Maryland and he like I have a
fascination with the great maestro
Galileo Galilei and behind me you'll
probably be able to describe this better
than I can
Mary Oh first of all how are you doing
in this in these unusual times yeah well
you know I'm sheltering in place at my
home not going anywhere because just
doing some short walks around the house
for a long time already mm-hmm
and unfortunately Maryland where I live
you still you know it's we're not yet
opening up yeah it's one of those states
that is not opening up yet so the first
thing I wanted to talk about is I
usually do with with guests that are
author
not all a guest on the in through the
impossible podcaster authors but since
you are many books of great renown I
want to start off with the cover of the
book as they say you know don't judge a
book by their covers don't judge a book
by its cover but I always judge books by
their covers I really I know how much
thought and intensity goes into the
creation of a cover from first-hand
experience so can you walk the audience
through the choice of the cover design
we'll put up a picture of it and and
even the title of the book let's start
there yeah so well the title you see
this is a biography of Galileo but
because Galileo had to deal with all
kinds of science deniers and because
science denialism is the way I see it a
big problem today then this is what
determined the title Galileo and the
science deniers namely it's a biography
of Galileo but with an eye on science
denial today so that's about the title
concerning the image on the cover so I
chose the very first portrait of Galileo
when he was relatively young probably in
his 40s it was done by an unknown Tuscan
painter but it's the very first portrait
known of him
usually people you know are familiar
with pictures of him by sister months
when he was all even there is one
attributed to Tintoretto and he was sort
of middle aged this one is is is the
earliest so that's that and then there
are these there is this figure of orbits
of planets around the Sun and the way
the cover was chosen is that his picture
is in the middle of that which makes it
look almost as if he is in the bullseye
of a target which kind of describes his
life so so that's how the
that cover was and of course the the
deeper kind of perspective of the target
of the bullseye that he lies at the
center of is the Copernican construction
of the cosmos and obviously we'll get
into that because it's a deeply
intertwined with not only Galileo
scientific accomplishments but also with
his with his identity I think his very
identity psychologically was tied up
along with the Copernican principle that
he we now call the Copernican principle
it really wasn't called that until I
think the 1930s with with bond and
Gautami gold and but the but the
Copernican dialogues and even his books
which tie nicely into your books as well
made me think that this is really a book
about about controversies and curiosity
and it's it had nice references to not
directly but in my mind it brought up
your previous books brilliant blunders
and and your more recent book why what
makes us curious and we'll get into
those a little bit because I can think
there is sort of a theme that runs
through those three books in particular
that I want to touch upon for the
audience I want to first begin with kind
of a deeper picture of why we should
have academic freedom even even at this
day or are we still kind of being
threatened as academics you're now
emeritus professor I understand
but but is academic freedom relevant to
today I don't I don't have the
government telling me what I should
research or what I shouldn't research or
my Dean or my Chancellor so can you talk
about academic freedom we discussed that
quite frequently on this on this very
podcast what does it mean to you and is
it relevant today sure let me just first
make a small correction I mean I'm not
formally an emeritus I'm a retired
retired okay okay I'm not an emeritus
very much yes now concerning the
situation with with academic freedom you
see the bigger question that I regard in
this book in particular but that always
has been very close to my heart is what
I would call intellectual free
which is a little bit even more than
academic freedom I mean it's not just
you know your ability to research what
you want and publish what you want and
so on but it is really it ties into into
things even like freedom of speech you
know that you should be entitled to your
opinions too and that's part of what I
call you also intellectual freedom and
Galileo's fight was largely a fight for
intellectual freedom it is often
described as if it was a clash between
science and religion which in fact it
wasn't in the Galileo never saw it as
such it was Galileo you know like all
people at his age were it was a
religious person his main point was that
the Bible is not a science book it was
written for the salvation of humans and
not to teach them science he pointed out
that you know in the case of astronomy
for example the planets aren't even
named in the Bible and the language used
he said was such that common people will
be able to understand it so basically
when science tells you something that
appears to be contradictory to literal
interpretations of biblical texts you
must change the interpretation you must
understand that that's not what the text
meant because the Galileo was convinced
that actually the Bible cannot to make
any errors
it's just our interpretation that can be
wrong so so really it is this
intellectual freedom this idea that you
should be able to research whatever you
want express whatever opinion you want
without any interference be it from any
type of officialdom you know no
governments no religious institutions
none of those should interfere with your
opinions as long of course as your
opinions don't harm anybody or don't
incite others to
somebody hmm yes I think you know that's
been a theme for a few guests I've had
on recently on the podcast including
Michael Shermer who's a well-known
skeptic atheist and but yet a valid and
vigorous vehement defender of free
speech even for people whose ideas he
calls devilish his new book is called
giving the devil is due and it's about
the freedom to express ideas even when
they're wrong
I'd like to talk a little bit about how
we we have in this book you know one
main controversy at the time which was
of course the Copernican versus the
Aristotelian system can you explain for
a little for the listeners that might
not be familiar what what is the
difference between the system that
Galileo promoted and the ER and the
system that seemingly the church and
Pope Urban later on famously went to to
defend so brutally in Galileo's case
yeah so you know there is two Italian in
the Pali Mike sometimes sometimes is
called system yes
was this geocentric system where the
earth was at the center and the planets
and the Sun in this case all revolved
around the earth and that fit very
nicely with the church's Catholic
Church's thinking because it basically
puts the earth and humans on earth at
the center of the universe so this is
why it has been adopted for many
centuries the Copernican system which is
the one that Galileo adopted said that
nodes actually the Sun is at the center
and the planets including the earth that
orbit the Sun and the earth is just
another planet just like the other
planets and and they all orbit the Sun
so this was the main difference mmm and
so what I thought about as I was reading
this is what would I am a devil side
which is ironically the god side in this
case the opposite side to Galileo was
the course the Catholic Church headed at
the Vatican by the Pope that you know
that we should sort of see it through
there
at least to understand why did they
believe so vehement ly in the position
that they did and I think a lot of it
comes down to one of the things that we
do here on the Arthur she Clark's Center
for human imagination on this into the
impossible podcast is that scientific
inquiry is the best method to go about
getting truth but sometimes it'll be
vehement Lee opposed by people who trust
their senses and I think Galileo was
kind of interesting to me because in
many cases he let his own biases so to
speak sneaked in to scientific arguments
and you outlined four cases that he made
in favor of the Copernican principle
which is the heliocentric model of the
world which we now know to be correct
but I often point out even to some of my
college students and I I would expect
it's true even in Johns Hopkins and I
know that for a fact actually but but
all around the world even some you know
college students who are physics majors
if I ask them if I say to them the world
is the earth is at the center of the
solar system the Sun goes around the
earth proof to prove me wrong I know
that's not the case but but I think it's
very difficult for the average person
let alone for a college student let
alone a layperson who's not interested
in science to prove many of these things
so they tend to take things based on
their senses and I think what Galileo
did for the first time is give human
beings extra sensory perception and I
want to walk us through what really
kicked off this notion in his mind was
the pioneering use of the telescope he
didn't invent it contrary to popular
myth about him he did many things but he
didn't invent the telescope but maybe
say what happened in the in the summer
fall of 1609 through the winter of 1610
that really revolutionized Galileo's
perspective on the universe yes so you
know it has been said that during those
months that you now mentioned the
Galileo made more discoveries than
almost any other person did in their
entire lifetime so indeed he did not
invent the telescope the telescope was
invented in the
but as soon as he heard about this he
immediately started to construct his own
telescopes and very quickly he
constructed better telescopes than any
ones that were available I mean the
typical telescopes that were there
available you know were a for power
telescope and he constructed telescopes
it were more than twenty power so he had
better telescopes than most but first of
all you know think about this I mean
people got a telescope what they would
do in places like in the venetian
republic they would what see you know
the sea ships at sea and things like
this
Galileo had the idea of turning these to
the heavens and and looking at what he
could see there and he started by
observing the moon and he observed the
moon and he saw features on the moon but
that's this is the amazing part that's
where his artistic education came in you
see because for example the British
astronomer Harriet also observed the
moon and saw the same features that
Galileo saw but really couldn't
understand them and you know just drew
some very very rough sketches from which
you cannot understand anything
Galileo from his understanding of light
and shadow and drawing he was able to
understand that what he's seeing is a
very rugged surface with craters and
mountains and he not only that he drew
them you know it he had these washed
drawings which were fantastic of the
surface of the Moon so already by that
he introduced something that is a huge
step towards modern science because what
that did you see until then there was
this feeling that thinks terrestrial and
think celestial are very very different
things
terrestrial you know they can get
corrupted they died and this in the
heavens everything is perfect there are
no blemishes nothing he showed no the
surface of the Moon is really very much
like the surface of the earth so already
he introduced this unification of
showing basically that things on earth
and things in the heavens are very
similar
then of course he went and observed
let's say you know not necessarily in
this order but Jupiter and found these
four satellites of Jupiter which today
we call the Galilean satellites this was
these were first of all the very first
object since antiquity newly discovered
in the solar system
second this looked like a mini solar
system in itself you know it had four
objects revolving around Jupiter it was
actually able to determine the periods
of revolution of this satellites to very
high precision but not only that you see
some of the people who objected to the
earth moving around the Sun said yeah
well if it's moving around the Sun how
is it possible that it's not losing its
moon for example and also why is it the
only planet that has a moon before you
know we discovered that what he did is
with his observation he killed both of
these objections because first of all he
discovered that other planets have moons
and second you see everybody agreed that
Jupiter revolves around something beat
the Earth or the Sun where the fact is
it revolves around something and it's
not losing four moons so there is no
problem for the earth not to lose its
moon so this was the other thing then
there was his observation of Venus that
was really you know like almost like an
last nail in the coffin of Aristotelian
ISM even though not fully but you know
to some extent the thing is that Venus
because Venus if Venus revolves around
the Sun it means that there is one point
when it is farthest from Earth and then
it should look smaller smaller and fully
lit and there is a point where it is
closest to
namely between the earth and the Sun in
which case it's the biggest and dark
basically and show some Crescent phases
in between really like the moon like our
home moon and that's what was what was
seen while if Venus was orbiting the
Earth it should always appear as some
sort of a crescent but never fool or you
know or dark so this was a very very
clear evidence that Venus was orbiting
the Sun he had other observations I
don't know if you want me to list them
all I mean you know he saw that there
were many stars in the Milky Way he
followed the the paths of sunspots on
the surface of the Sun and determined
that they are on the surface of the Sun
and from that determined that the Sun
spins around its axis which actually
removed another objection to
Copernicanism because they said well if
the earth is moving
how come it's it can move all the time
and not stop well here he found that the
Sun was also moving you know or spinning
around its axis and not stopping and so
on so all these observations really
added all of them added something to
this idea of Copernicanism yes of course
they added to it too again I'm gonna
take the side of the Pope ironically but
but none of them were pruvit of of this
fact in fact it wasn't proven that the
earth truly goes around the Sun and not
the other way around for almost a
century right until the study of
operations took over but but I think
you're you're absolutely right giving
evidence is incredibly important one
piece of evidence you left out is of
course the most interesting part ii mean
from a psychological perspective and i
think this book is as much as a
psychological profile written from the
perspective for the very first time i
believe your book is the first portrait
of galileo as a biography by an
astronomer i think is that correct i
mean you're not a theologian you're not
a historian but but you're over an
astrophysicist I don't think we'd had
such a biographies all right III think
that is true at least none of the
well-known biographies were written by
by active astronomers or astrophysicists
so the piece of evidence he left out was
of course
Galileo's claim of the tides that caused
in the oceans were generated by the sort
of combined motion of revolution and
rotation rotation on its axis and
revolution around the Sun both of which
were essentially you know found to be
heretical at a time we'll get we'll get
a little bit more into that when we
discuss Galileo in in the in the the
dialog oh the dialogue and - chief
world-systems so-called that got him
into the most trouble but let's go back
to 1616 when I find it so fascinating
that I of course knew that in 1616 he
was really scolded and warned not to
teach you know that the heliocentric
model but what I found most interesting
just to be honest with you Mario was
that there were these Jesuits there were
these priests and they were studying
math and science and I always say when
I'm talking to a religious people they
say you know why do so many you know why
are so many scientists atheist and I say
well why don't you know more about
science than you actually do I think in
the past because I think it's a vehicle
if you believe and your book doesn't
make a case for atheism in any sense of
the word but I think if you want to know
more about the world if you believe it
was created then then it should impel
you to learn more about the universe and
know more about science what do you make
of the fact that in the 1600s the early
1600s there were so many Jesuits
interested in astronomy was that merely
to fend off attacks by people like
Galileo and Bruno and others no I
definitely don't think so and this is
why I say that it is a mistake to think
that the Galileo story is a clash
between science and religion the
Catholic Church actually employed some
of the best scientists of the time at
the Collegio Romano it is you know the
Roman College in Rome and
they were excellent mathematicians and
very very good scientists so what is
true however you know one has to admit
is that a number of them still were
unable to somehow isolate themselves
from the teachings of of the church and
you know be completely open-minded about
their scientific discoveries at least
some of them that was the case or you
know or maybe it was a matter of
education and you know the way that they
have been brought up and things like
that because certainly for example they
confirmed the reality of Galileo's
observations you know at first he had to
fight to even convince people that what
you see with the telescope too
represents a reality and it's not some
artifact of the telescope but they
actually agreed that these were really
the things that are out there that you
see with a with a telescope it was more
the interpretation of the results where
they had some trouble and if you see
what happened is that most of those
Jesuits while accepting all of Galileo's
findings they some somehow discovered a
fallback position
there was this hybrid model of Tycho or
Tycho Brahe's is sometimes called where
you you know everything revolved around
the Sun except the Earth and the Sun
itself revolved around the earth and
even with Galileo's observations it was
virtually impossible to show that this
model is wrong but the Galileo you know
I had the opinion of of modern scientist
who says if you have two models that
explain things equally well you choose
the simpler one I mean for him Bryce
you know in our language it too many
moving parts and so we didn't accept
that but his observations could not
quite argue against it even though we
know today that his observations of
sunspots and the motion of sunspots
actually could show conclusively that
the Copernican model was correct but
that he didn't know that yeah that was
sort of poetic justice perhaps that it
was that it could have taken him to a
level of proof but I doubt given all the
other evidence that he provided they
also didn't know that his explanation
for the tides was wrong so I doubt you
know I came away from the book doubting
that if they had really appreciated or
thought more about the Sun SPOT evidence
which i think is very strong that they
would have been convinced by that if
they weren't convinced by the other
observations that he that he employed
and again you know I think it's
important to say what was he actually
proving or disproving I think he was
merely with the observations at least of
the medici satellites he was very smart
and cunning politically in some ways he
named the moons of Jupiter after his
patrons and I think is we do that
nowadays too with the Simon with the
Simon's observatory etc but but in
reality I think you know he he also was
a victim he you paint a portrait of him
as a human being which I think on many
cases is very valid and I've talked
about this with other with other guests
that we when we portray somebody like an
Einstein and and Stephen Hawking as a
scientist it's true on the other hand it
kind of does a disturbance because
they're almost like otherworldly and
Galileo was kind of otherworldly when
you look at his successes but when you
look at the scientist as a man or as a
woman then you can can realize that they
have their own flaws and none of this is
to excuse the treatment of Galileo but
can you say something about what you
came away with in your impressions of
Galileo as a human being what vice is
what what sorts of just normal human
behavior I always think of him as you
know kind of this paragon of science
but like most scientists he was
susceptible to certain biases including
those that were tightly wrapped up with
his ego so we're gonna say something
about him as a human yeah
gorilla was really not the nicest person
I would say he was he was a real zealot
he was a zealot and he you know he could
be very nice to members of his own
family
but boy if you were against him did he
use a sharp pen against you and he
really--he he never held back I mean no
one could criticize him and not you know
feel his wrath it was not the nicest
person he he was also you know he had
his own problems in his personal life
you know he never married the woman with
whom he had his children he put two of
his daughters in a convent and that was
not so unusual at the time except that
I'm still a little bit puzzled by why
didn't he put them in a somewhat better
convent and the one he did put them here
even though that was convenient because
it was not too far from his home in in
archery so he did that he definitely was
wrong he was wrong
a number of times I mean you mentioned
the tides his theory of the tides who
was completely wrong it was it was
interesting because it had this
mechanical aspect to it which you know
was some of his trademark and he he
didn't like forces that acted across
distance you know like gravity which you
don't see so in in that respect it was
an interesting theory but it was
completely wrong here the theory of
comets which was completely wrong I mean
it had some interesting again elements
to it but it was wrong I mean he did not
believed that these were real objects
you know orbiting the Sun and so on so
it definitely was wrong on occasion he
fought with equal strength when he was
wrong as when he was right and and yeah
and like I say he wasn't the nicest
person however I will still say his
fight for intellectual freedom was far
beyond you know just trying to be right
I mean when you read what he wrote you
know about not interpreting the Bible as
a science book I mean that is just so
convincing especially to somebody
reading it today but but his point was
always so well taken in that and his
language was incredible because he was
first in in poetry and you know and in
the arts so he he could write well so
yeah but at the same time he was
extremely sarcastic on many occasions
sometimes rightfully so sometimes
somewhat less rightfully so so he
definitely was a human being he for
awhile drank a lot enjoyed women quite a
bit and yeah and of course in his
interaction with the church he appeared
to be not always completely truthful in
the sense that clearly he was very
frightened especially at old age he was
afraid of being tortured he was well
aware of what happened to Giordano Bruno
was burnt at the stake and he was really
fearful yeah yeah I mean the church had
you know this kind of authoritarian
power over the affairs of people
throughout the lands of Italy that they
influenced that you make the point that
I made a very poor decision in
retrospect to kind of leave the Venetian
Padua and kind of sphere of influence
and move to move to Florence to avoid
teaching now I'll do anything to get out
of teaching but I don't think I want to
get my books on the index or get get
threatened with torture let me as I did
with Galileo let me ask the kind of
other side of the coin and again acting
as the devil but defending the Pope or
the opposite side of Galileo you know
what what should the Pope have made
again back then even even advanced
sophisticated colleagues or not I won't
say colleagues if they were actually
enemies of Galileo and in some sense but
they're people like Copernicus and and
others to Cobra hey they had you know
ideas of the universe that we would say
are really you know are completely wrong
Aristotle of course you know being being
among them Ptolemais etcetera are they
deniers I mean were you worried about
using the term denier whenever I see it
you know I read a book as for physics
today as a book review called the number
of the heavens by Tom Siegfried it
really talks about the multiverse and in
it I criticized him for using the term
denier he calls it multiverse deniers
like Paul Steinhardt or other people I
found it a very charged term I you know
I feel some some terms should be used
for real you know awful awful
intellectual over sites such as denying
the Holocaust or perhaps you know
climate changes you make in this case
even though I don't think those are
equivalent either were you worried about
that I'm using such a such a potentially
loaded term that maybe some listeners
might might be put off by no I wasn't
worried but I will say that there is no
doubt that using that term was
influenced by the fact that I was so
alarmed by science denial today hmm
truly alarmed and and and as you can see
through the boat route the book it's a
biography of Galileo but constantly with
an eye on what's happening today and
those were thinks that that true are
really troublesome and it's mainly
troublesome look I mean it's one thing
if people you know still believe let's
say in creationism instead of let's say
you know Darwinian evolution or
something like that that you know I
think is not a good idea and certainly
it shouldn't be taught in science
classes but it doesn't have an immediate
effect on our lives but when you have
things such as climate change or how to
treat the current copy 19 pandemic and
you have science denial in that case so
these are cases where people are betting
against science while putting the future
of life on Earth in danger and I think
that that is truly insane to do that I
mean it's never a good idea to bet
against science because science has this
you know wonderful ability to
self-correct even if it sometimes takes
takes time so it's not that science is
always right but science does
self-correct
and you know I mean for example you know
people would say all the initial models
for coverage 19 say that there will be
200,000 dead in the US and now they say
it's only 74,000 you know the models
they say sure because these are
mathematical models and they rely on
inputs that you put in from data and as
your data become better then the models
you know can change this does not make
them wrong I mean it's it's just this is
the way science really works but science
is a discipline where you can test
things where you can falsify things
which is extraordinarily important
and so that was constantly on my mind
when I wrote this book on Galileo and
the denial in his case again it's not
the fact that people were religious it
is the fact that they couldn't accept
the fact that interpretations of
biblical texts could be wrong not that
the Bible itself is wrong the human
interpretation of those takes could be
wrong this was gonna last point you know
he made it again in his usual sarcastic
fashion he said that he didn't believe
that the same God who has given us our
senses and reason wanted us to abandon
their use so you know I mean he said
when you have a conflict between what
observations and reasoning tell you and
interpretation of text you should change
the interpretation of the text hmm so
another thing that struck me in the book
is Galileo as a as a businessman as a
head of an enterprise a CEO of an
industry Galileo incorporated my friend
and we did an event together at UCSD I'm
in 2010 on their 400th anniversary of
the publication of Siderius nuncius
Mario Bo Jolie he basically makes a very
convincing case in his book
Galileo's instruments of credit that you
know what Galileo wanted to do was kind
of two things there were almost at odds
with each other he wanted to attain you
know prestige fame make more money have
more influence but he also wanted to
avoid attention you know sort of from me
people that were potentially would view
his findings with suspicion I think it's
impossible to say that he wasn't warned
you know and didn't know and you make
this case in in the book where you kind
of go back and get and you make the case
that in the famous trial of 1634 that he
believed you know he would make
statements that seem to like reject the
Copernican
or argue on behalf of the Pope Urban's
view for example and I think you know
what's so interesting about when you say
we should believe in science I you and I
are both signs I mean we know the
scientists are human we know that
scientists make mistakes I think in this
case it's scientists have a propensity
that is good to be anti Authority and
that we shouldn't look to Authority for
the answer
Einstein as you point out and and many
other scientists and Darwin as well in
brilliant blunders you point out that
they make mistakes and that that did a
very good service by showing scientists
as human beings and and so I think it's
very interesting that Galileo had this
dual mandate and he was extremely I
reminds me like a hermit crab or one of
those fiddler crabs that you see on the
beach here sometimes in San Diego and
maybe in Baltimore before you eat them
in the crab crab district but these
fiddler crabs that are really extremely
well developed on one side of their claw
and the other side is like atrophied
they never use it I don't know why
genetic or not genetically but
biologically that is the case but it
seems like he was incredibly brilliant
when it came to scientific matters and
even cultivating a monopoly on this
telescope I mean he wouldn't even share
it with Tico with Keppler right but on
the other hand he was incredibly in
politic he didn't seem to understand the
way that his ideas and his message could
be crafted you go through the episode of
the dialogue we'll turn to that now
where his famous book on the two
different systems of the world written
in this of this exchange over four days
is a dialogue and he puts the words of
the Pope namely aristotelianism into the
mouth of a character named simply Co can
you talk a little bit about some Plessy
oh and his psychological motives in that
book yes so so in that book he he it's a
conversation between among three people
one plays the role of Galileo himself
one plays the role of an Aristotelian
and one plays the role of educated but
non scientist who listens to the other
two so the guy who plays Galileo basic
argues for the Copernican system the gut
simply CEO simply to Yahoo the name is
coined after a known Aristotelian
supporter but also has a connotation of
being the simpleton he plays the role he
talks about the Aristotelian system and
educated person is is named after a
personal friend of Galileo and for
anybody who reads that book it is easy
to see that girl alone more or less
ridicules simply - and you know and his
ideas about you know geocentric model
but Galileo also knew that he will not
get permission to publish the book in
this way and well I don't know if he
knew that but it was pointed out to him
by his friends and so he added the
preface and the coda in which he more or
less said oh well actually it's all you
know just the model in a way and it's
inconclusive at the end the problem was
that again anybody who read the book
wasn't particularly convinced by the
preface and in the conclusion or the
coda they they did look like an
afterthought and consequently you know
he was eventually put on trial but so he
wasn't politically smart in that way but
you know I I like to think that he was
also at some level naive because he he
had he had a great opinion of himself
and justifiably so in the sense that he
was very very smart and his arguments
you know against literal interpretations
extremely powerful so he felt I think
that once he puts you know this caveat
at the beginning it at the end that is
enough and the fact is believe it or not
that you know in pioppi skinny was this
person who was asked in the middle of
the twentieth century to write a
biography of Galileo and he was a person
off the church asked by the church to
write that biography he basically
concluded that Galileo was fair and it
was not his fault that the Copernican
argument was much stronger than there
are is totally on one and you know it's
telling that church actually prohibited
the publication of pure persky's book
even though they ordered it hmm that's
really fascinating it's it's funny to
think about how yeah time and time again
in history as Mark Twain said doesn't
repeat itself but it rhymes and towards
the end of the again as I said before we
went on to live recording this I said to
you offline yeah I don't like to give
away the whole book because I want
people to read this book it reads it
reads so interestingly it's it's a work
of nonfiction it's a work of science
science biography and it's written by a
professional astrophysicist one of the
greatest to use although you haven't
used many refractors as far as I know
I've used more refractors than you have
I think I'm a theorist you you you you
are an observer yeah when you use the
Hubble telescope and you've made my
major discoveries throughout your
throughout your storied career so I want
to turn to back to the Pope again I just
think it's more interesting if I kind of
take a little bit of a gentle
adversarial discussion but the thing you
know that I kept thinking about is what
view Mario Livio what if your emperor of
the planet and your astronomers and you
support your National Science Foundation
so heavily that you've got the greatest
telescopes in the world and you're you
planetary astronomers they discover an
asteroid and the asteroids coming right
towards the earth and it's gonna hit the
earth and with 0% chance of missing the
earth is going to devastate all of life
on earth what would you do
do you have an obligation to keep the
peace even if it means not lying through
oh you know Co mission but lying through
omission perhaps what would you do as
you know Emperor Pope
mario livio uh I don't know it's it's a
hard question I I'm not sure if to
understand your question in the way that
there is nothing I can do to actually
stop it yeah there's nothing you can do
that's that what I'm getting at is does
a government or the papacy back in the
17th century
do they have an obligation to kind of
keep the peace is there an obligation to
provide panic even if we know it's
inevitable or even if the science is not
decidable at with the instruments and
knowledge of that time well is there you
know should they have was it so bad of
them to keep to try to keep the peace
obviously I don't believe this but I'm
just kind of making this devil's
advocate position for you to consider
what obligations did the Pope have I
mean what if this got out could it be
dangerous could it undermine the entire
credulity in the in the biblical
narratives for example yeah well I still
think that in that case the actions of
the Pope did not come from that type of
motivation it came from type of
motivations that yes there was already
you know the 30 Years War so the war
there was a clash between Protestants
and Catholics that the Pope was very
aware of there were problems that the
Pope was having internally because this
particular pope urban the eighth spent
money like there was no tomorrow
there was nepotism that he appointed his
his nephews to various positions and so
on and is so his entire attitude was
really more of a person who
felt personally you know under pressure
and not because you know he necessarily
believed that this is the best course
for Christianity or humanity I don't
think that he did that you know
concerning should one keep the peace if
an asteroid is about to destroy Earth
without any without any possibility to
avoid that I don't know I don't think
one should keep quiet about it in the
same way that I don't think anybody
should have to say dumb you know that
when the current pandemic started that
oh there are now only 15 cases in very
soon it will be down to zero you know
when all scientists were saying exactly
the opposite so III don't think that
this is a good strategy I think that
telling the truth even in difficult
times is is a pretty essential I mean
yes one can encourage people you know I
mean you know during world war two you
know Churchill famously you know say it
will fight them on the beaches it will
fight them in the streets I mean you did
not say oh oh no they are never gonna
come here and nothing is gonna happen
you know and so on he basically said
look it's really bad and we would have
to do everything we can you fight them
so so I think yeah that's my opinion so
I want to talk now I'm gonna stop being
a devil now at least for the time being
I want to talk about
Galileo's the end of his life obviously
the story that your account of his trial
is incredibly gripping and much has been
made of it in media and even in the
press and even the not hard and
technically I don't think that pope john
paul ii pardoned Galileo in 1992 but but
but instead kind of the aftermath of the
affair
again I want people to read the book so
I'm showing now in the back of my screen
some scenes that I took from our Chhetri
which is the final home house
imprisonment that Galileo enjoyed I put
enjoyed in quotes although I do think
you know if you have to be at home in
prison we ran a conference there in 2015
on the subject of testing relativity and
of course you make the point in here
Galileo was one of the first if not the
first to consider what is meant by
relativity so much so the relative
motions of objects and their behaviors
so much so that Einstein and his in one
of his books in his works he cited
Galileo is really the originator of this
idea of the principle of relative motion
now Galileo was imprisoned here
beginning in 1634 until his death in
1642 I think so eight years eight or so
years the Pope was not he seemed like a
real difficult person who was very it
seemed tyrannical oppressive almost
vindictive in many cases but he did
allow him to live in this rather sum she
was villa which we as I said I had a
conference there I spent three days in
the villa we lived near it and ate there
every day and beside from from hiding my
head on the ceiling because the ceilings
are very low there because people's
height said back then gluten Galileo's
were kind of a good ten to fifteen
centimeters shorter than I am it didn't
seem that bad
so was did the Pope do him sort of give
him any special kindness or was that
just sort of an accident
that he was allowed to live both near
his his daughter celesta the sisters
Maria celesta
I don't know if his other daughter was
at the same convent but you can see it
here I think it was yeah so talk about
you know if he wasn't treated like you
know Jeffrey Epstein I mean he was just
put into a pretty decent arrangement he
was essentially under house house arrest
and you know as I say the surroundings
are are pretty nice so what was life
like for him in imprisonment he did
write more books after he was in prison
correct he wrote a very important book
who they described all his experiments
in mechanics
these ideas yeah well get to that yeah
we'll talk about why they are saying yes
but well look Galileo was probably the
best known scientist in Europe and he
actually was a personal friend of the
Pope before he wrote the dialogue oh so
it was quite and he was also old he was
you know already in the 70s oh he was
already quite all so there was no
question that he would really be put to
torture and in addition there are some
speculations that maybe there was even
some sort of a plea bargain during the
trial which you know he confessed and
you know did his observation and as a
result of that he was given a somewhat
more lenient treatment and you know more
not so severe a punishment but but the
punishment was still there I mean he was
on house arrest for you know eight and a
half years or so and you know there were
lots of restrictions there were he could
get visitors but he couldn't get many
visitors he couldn't discuss many things
even when he died they wanted to do a
big you know tuned for him and the Pope
objected to that they still didn't allow
him to publish more books in fact even
the printing of his previous books was
disallowed in Italy so so so so it's not
that he wasn't punished he was punished
but yeah he wasn't burnt at the stake
and and yeah tortured so behind - yeah
go had a humiliation he had to go
through you know by giving his up
duration on his knees before the
inquisitors you know a person
seventy years old was sufficient I think
may remind you he was never very healthy
- I mean he suffered from lots of
illnesses wrong most of his life yeah
and the story of his kind of delay of
trial and is just so gripping it reads
like a like a true courtroom drama so
you're to be commended as usual I'm
showing in the back for those of you
watching on YouTube you can see it some
of the olive trees and the grape trees
that are in Galileo Sevilla olio and
there's uh it's it's it's such a
peaceful genteel place to be as I said
it's much better than saying what Bernie
Madoff quote unquote might be enjoying
as we speak just a quick note on his
daughter you know a lot of books focus
on Galileo or focus on scientists and
their relationships with their fathers
and my book sort of covers that what's
so interesting in Davis OBO who endorsed
your book saying such lovely words as
every so often a reason arises to tell
retell the life of Galileo this year as
mario livio so forcefully demonstrates
in galileo on the science deniers the
400-year galileo galilei affair casts an
urgent new light on the current climate
crisis that's davis ovo offer of
longitude Galileo's daughter and the
class universe and she wrote very
tenderly about their relationship and
how devastating it was for Galileo when
he passed away what about that you have
daughters if I remember yes and I have
daughters I do daughters and his son yes
so um what was gal like Galileo like as
a father as a scientist father you know
to boot he was his father well you know
had had high hopes for him unfortunately
he let him down he became a he became a
scientist not a doctor and reminds me of
Hubble his father wanted him to become a
lawyer
and you know these great scientists you
know renowned for their use of
telescopes and defied their fathers to
go on to great great accomplishments for
all of humanity but tell me a little bit
about Galileo as a son and as a father
especially with his
with his son vincenzo and his daughter
celeste yeah so is a son you know his
father was a musician is and a music
theorist he almost certainly helped his
his father in experiment
his father Vincenzo was was himself a
very stubborn and you know not
particularly giving in to Authority a
person and he wrote a book against the
musical theories of his own teacher in
music and gorilla almost certainly
inherited some of this objection to
authority from his father no question
about that concerning his daughter so he
had two daughters and a son
unfortunately at the time there was a
big difference between women and men in
the sense that to marry a daughter you
needed to have a dowry and because all
his children were illegitimate because
he never married the woman that was the
mother of his children the dowry for his
daughters who were illegitimate
daughters would have been just
incredible and beyond his means and as a
result of that he put them in the
convent which was not unusual at the
time like I said now one of his
daughters never adjusted to to the
convent life really and we know almost
nothing about her except a little bit
which we know from the letters of his
other daughter this daughter sister
maria celeste she wrote to galileo and
you know more than a hundred over
letters survived and Dava Sobel so
beautifully described those letters and
in addition to her book she actually
published a translation of all of those
letters
those letters are really moving I mean
they are moving in particular in what
she writes to him I mean you know first
of all the respect with which she treats
him and but but you know when she died
she died it in her 30s this was a huge
shock for Galileo and he wrote to a
friend that you know we had this
daughter who was so smart and so loving
of him and and so on he was clearly
devastated by her by her death
no question about that and she took care
actually off of his Villa and of you
know you mentioned the olive tree is the
olives and the wine and so on when he
was during this trial so he was a very
loving but the son because there was no
issue of dowry with the son the son was
eventually made legitimate by by the
Grand Duke and he actually uh so he
lived a rather peaceful life he was near
Galileo when he died and yeah and that's
it but but but but the life of the
daughters was was really tough yeah I'm
showing in the background of my video
that I took from the Italian this is the
University of our Chhetri in outside of
Florence and you can see one of their
teaching telescope domes and even in the
back you can see another dome as Duomo
in Florence down now this is not far
they are the stewards of Galileo's villa
where he lived out the rest of his life
after this imprisonment I wanna I know
the video will probably get people to be
nauseous I'm gonna turn it back to a
photo of the same area which is much
more be colic and peaceful again this is
Galileo's a final final resting place
final place where he did science here's
a picture that doe
very imposing door wooden medieval
looking door it's quite striking here's
the night shot of the of the of the
entryway seen from the courtyard here's
the courtyard itself with a bunch of
Italian physicist I know in the
background taking pictures this is a
panoramic view I want to finish up the
discussion of the book with the last
book that Galileo ever wrote and then I
want to talk a little bit about books in
general to you in the remaining few
minutes you have a few more minutes to
go sure okay great so when I read this
book and I finished it finishes up with
the discussion of the disc or C which is
the discourse on two systems of the
world and you make the point what that
really means and I'll leave it to the
reader to read what what the
interpretation of these two systems and
he seemed to use this dialectic
methodology quite a bit and it made me
think of pedagogy today and one of the
things that took me struck me so
powerfully from your last book why what
makes us curious I'll put this up I know
we'll feed it in there kind of a view of
it anyway we'll put up a link to it in
the notes but you make the case for it
in Y for pedagogy in a way that really
struck me as I was reading the book the
new book Galilei on the science deniers
and that's that and you're gonna think
this is crazy but we should teach the
controversy you ever heard that phrase
before teach the controversy Mario well
I heard that you know usually news media
they like controversy yeah it's usually
in the context of creationists that say
oh you should teach the Contra that
there is a controversy that between
Darwin Darwin had these significant
doubts and and Bobby should teach
intelligent design on an equal footing
with creationism that's typically what
they mean by that I'm just being a
little bit tongue-in-cheek here what I
mean is the controversy that you really
illuminate in the dial and the discourse
II you talk about how Galileo you say
incline planes now I don't know if you
will remember or how teaching was done
for you when you were you grew up but
for me when I was introduced to inclined
planes and balls and things rolling down
and it was the most stupefyingly boring
you know not
form of Education but then I started
thinking about what she said in the book
why when you talk about well how do you
teach the law of gravity to a young kid
you teach them him or her about the
dinosaurs yes how do the dinosaurs die
well they're hit by a huge asteroid and
then how did that asteroid get here I
was attracted by gravity and you don't
start off with the inverse square law
right and I started thinking well what
if we taught physics majors and
especially non majors what if we said
here's this controversy here's this book
where these principles were laid out and
and it was the result of this book came
about as a result of a huge controversy
revolving around the very interpretation
of of the Word of God if you will and
the word of science and I wonder you
know what do you think about like
teaching as a teaching method to make
things more visceral and to make
children more curious and asking why you
know why you start off this book was
written in prison and and what we know
about inclined planes is written by a
man it was imprisoned at the time I mean
what don't you think that would pique
their curiosity oh yeah I think you know
certainly sort of a human story added to
this and in storytelling always you know
works I mean you're right that you you
know when I grew up we actually solved
problems on inclined planes to death
when I studied physics till there and
and it really you know you must have you
know I I remember I was thinking you
know what how many times am I gonna use
this inclined plane and you know not
once
I don't remember once somebody telling
me you know why we even talk about
inclined planes because Galileo was
really trying to study freeform
yeah but he had no good way to measure
short times so we had to slow motion to
slow the motion to a point where he
could make more precise measurement and
had this incredible idea of slowing down
the motion by rolling balls down
inclined planes at a very small angle
because that allowed him to measure the
times better you know and so on and not
only that he had this intuition that
freefall can be seen as an extreme case
of an inclined plane that is at 90
degrees you talk to the ground so nobody
ever mentioned this to me when I studied
these things and I think that if you
tell people that you know I think they
get a better feeling of you know what
kind of insights were involved in this
inclined planes absolutely and miR you
know my complimentary suggestion to what
you're saying is also to teach a little
bit of the history you know yet we
always teach science as discoveries you
know or punctuated by Nobel prizes and
and an attention but we never really
talk about the human beings behind these
discoveries and how interesting would
that be and make it much more visceral
and likely for people to remember you
know here I'm showing the picture of his
villa where you know he might have been
ruminating I like to think about him
walking around here and this is on the
second floor and we overlooking where
the kitchen was that they would eat back
then and I just think it's so
fascinating to think about how these
arose from basically this you know
ultimate controversy of all which is you
know how does the universe house the
universe organized is this mankind play
any sort of special role within it and
so it's fascinating I think it could
combine your book Y with your book
Galileo on the science and I really
stimulate curiosity in a way that's
uniquely perhaps well-suited to Galileo
in particular I want to finish up by a
discussion of you know kind of just a
current event perhaps involving things
in the news while we're doing this
remotely instead of in-person we did an
event of two years ago now with you in
person here in San Diego have you here
so now of course we're all shut down
because of the Cova 19 emergency that's
going around the world
what can you
say about that from the perspective of
Galileo or what lessons would Galileo
have to teach us about how to handle
such things as this you know again you
you already mentioned that phrase which
I mentioned in the book which is
believed in science you know we should
have taken the advice of the scientists
here from the beginning then we should
continue to follow them I mean look let
me just give you a very very simple
example I mean the task force that deals
with with the cop in nineteen pandemic
issued very very clear guidelines to you
know what should it take for various
states to open you know to reopen
businesses and things like that and so
on very very clear guidelines and the
guidelines say you should have 14 days
of declining you know numbers of cases
and new cases and all that you know and
so on and yet we are faced now where a
situation which you know almost 20
states open without having that that
really means not following the science
now of course I hope very much that
nothing really bad will happen as a
result of this and of course I realize
that everybody wants to open yes I mean
clearly I mean we're all stuck at home
and not doing what what we want to do
and what we can do and our people who
are losing their businesses and their
people who hardly have even what to eat
and so on this is horrible
but those guidelines were put together
by a bunch of scientists who sat down
and really thought what it takes to
actually overcome this pandemic so you
cannot just ignore that you know all
together so I think guerrilla would have
been as terrified as I am from this type
of of reaction you know because you
would not understand why people are not
following the advice of those who are
experts in these types
mm-hmm the last thing related
specifically to the book is this famous
motto and you can say it in Italian
because I can't and yet it moves can you
say something about this unique kind of
pursuit that you undertook in the
writing of this book to understand how
of that phrase originated first say it
in Italian please it borders team Wally
Porter see more of a and what does that
mean and what is the truth and the
fictions around the way famous phrase
well I can tell you what it means it
mean this was referring to the earth yes
and legend has it that you know after
finishing everything and so on he sort
of muttered this phrase and yet it moves
you know and yet the earth moves I took
I did the whole years of risk worth of
research trying to find out the origin
of this motto and I did find that out
now I will not tell you what the result
is here now however on May 5th which is
in a few days from today I published an
article well it will be published in
Scientific American on the results of
net of that motto
but look irrespective of whether this is
a myth or not I mean the motto has
become you know like a symbol of
intellectual defiance basically saying
in spite of what you may believe these
are the facts and and as such it applies
to so many situations even today
but very good so I like to finish up the
conversation with what I call the final
five and when that involves the
following questions that I like to start
off just conclude most of my discussions
with and that involves the meaning first
starting with the meaning of books in
your life and one thing I always like to
kind of you know present to other
authors is what what your preference is
if you were to have somebody pick up
this book a hundred years from now but
it's just one reader would you prefer
that to say having a hundred readers or
a thousand readers one year from now
okay we all want a lot of book sales
when the book first comes out but I'm
talking about the lasting impact is it
more important to have longevity or to
have the breadth of influence of this
books ideas well ideally you'd if both
can't say both that's good but do I want
charity or direct now yeah would you
rather have let me just say it would you
rather have a hundred readers one year
from now or one reader a hundred years
from now I see well you know books maybe
this book is maybe for this book I would
prefer longevity but for books in
general I mean and especially books that
are related to science they only have a
certain length of lifetime so and after
which they become sort of dated I
certainly hope that this one would not
but but generally books on science
become dated and so for those certainly
I would you know would want a very large
readership now because they would become
dated anyhow so yeah along those lines
when I was reading your book it reminded
me I bought a copy of Galileo's book
the military compass which is you know
perhaps in some sense is one of the
rarest books of all those books even
though obviously the serious nuncius and
the dialogue oh we're we're banned
during the end the index of prohibited
books but I started reading there's an
English translation you can get it's
beautiful has the Italian actually the
lat
I think it's the Latin I don't remember
if he was writing in Italian back then
another Siderius nuncius is in it is in
Latin and then the dialogue Oh famously
was in Italian but anyway I'm reading
the English translation because I don't
speak Italian or Latin and I came across
a passage where Galileo is talking about
this use of the military compass in what
we would call nowadays currency
conversions in other words you want to
convert euros to dollars this way of
manipulating the compass could be used
to do that and it's really just a matter
of a scale factor what we call a scale
factor now but the exemplary use I think
as he talks about converting you know
scooty to do cos CD scooty Scootie to do
that D and I started thinking like if
you could find a scudi today you know it
might be worth a little bit I mean you
can find Roman coins you know from 2000
years ago and buy them for a couple of
dollars at an antique show so certainly
one scooty is not worth that much but
then you look at the prices of a Galileo
compass if you just kept the compass
book the first editions worth you know
is almost you know priceless yeah well
because you only printed like 60 copies
or something like that and they start to
deteriorate so I just thought it was
cute that he has his book that's four
hundred and twenty years old basically
and the currency conversions if he had
done them or left it to his son Vincenzo
and his daughter who survived perhaps
well she was a nun so she didn't have
plenty many progeny one expects I want
to talk one more question only she died
before him so I didn't mean Celeste the
other whoa okay so the other question I
rap about books is what would you like
your target audience to be would you
rather have it be people that are you
know kind of fanatical supporters of
Galileo or would you rather have it be
science deniers themselves
well again I would like it to be both to
be honest but I will tell you something
I mean I've seen many studies which show
that once adult people are convinced of
something it is virtually impossible to
change their opinions even if you show
them facts and and so in this case I
wouldn't say supporters of Galileo but I
would say I would like every sort of
educated person you know to read this
book concerning the issue of how do you
change opinions I think there is no
escape from doing that from very early
on namely the education system for
children because once they become adults
and have strong opinions it turns out
it's very very difficult to change those
mm-hmm
very good okay just a couple more
questions one now turn to involves what
you're optimistic about in the future
and what you might be a little more
pessimistic about coming about in the
near future but either scientifically
politically culturally what have you um
I think you know one thing that you know
I would say almost keeps me up at night
is inequality inequality I see that as
one of the biggest problem that that you
know our world is facing because you
have these places you know you live in
San Diego there is a you know just south
of you there is a border with Central
America and there is a huge disparity on
the two sides of that border similarly
if you look between Europe and Africa
you know the Mediterranean there is a
huge disparity on both sides of that
border there used to be a huge disparity
between Western and Eastern Europe it's
somewhat less now but still there is a
big disparity
and those things are are very
problematic and I honestly don't even
know of good solutions for them but I
see those things as being a serious
problem now of course there are things
like climate change that worry me I mean
people we do need to do something about
this there is no question in my mind and
we need to do is what am i optimistic
about you know I I I do feel you know
even now it is horrible times of of
Corbett 19 you did you do see here and
there you see the goodness of people
coming out you know I mean when I do my
short walks around the house now and
with a mask and other people go you know
we all say hello to each other you know
people that I don't even know who they
are
and and you see you know people who try
to support others in things like this
and you see lots of acts of kindness to
in very many places that somehow you
know gives you the hope that maybe there
is that maybe there is hope to humans
yeah on the scientific part I always
hoped that during my lifetime we will
find life elsewhere and we haven't yet
and I am now not young anymore so I
don't know if I will live to see it I
actually believe that within twenty to
thirty years we will either find life
elsewhere or at least we will have some
meaningful constraint about how rare
life is in the galaxy now but the
problem is that I'm not sure that I will
leave 20 to 30 more years so I may miss
only on that so the last question really
involves something that is close to our
hearts here at the arthur c clarke
center you might be familiar with Sir
Arthur Khaleesi
famous three laws of culture science
society what have you is first law being
that that Li there's any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
that's his second as first law his third
law is mm is that for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert or
something that Isaac Newton would put
into place later on thanks to the work
of the of Galileo as you point out in
the book but the second law is the one
that our podcast name is taken from and
that's the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible is to venture a
little way past them into the impossible
and I'm wondering what about your life
your work seemed impossible maybe as a
young person in your 30s or 40s that now
seems possible because you did venture a
little bit beyond your comfort zone into
what we call the impossible you know I'm
not sure I mean life has changed so much
and technology in particular has changed
so much that I'm convinced that many
things that today we take for granted I
saw is absolutely impossible when I was
a child I mean you know to ever to be
able to to do this conversation now in
the way we do it you know I could not
have this is how we would do it I still
remember that as a child we were always
told it one day people will be able to
talk on the phone and actually see the
person that they are talking to and you
know I thought whoa would I ever see
that so so yeah I'm not sure exactly
what I did which which was impossible I
mean I think that society as a whole did
many things that look impossible and we
benefit from that AI probably will be
impossible of the relatively near future
I think you know
big advances in ni I think you know to
the point maybe even that they become
the dominant intelligent civilization
that will be a topic for another time
Mary I want to thank you so much dr.
Mario Livio author of Galileo and the
science deniers a wonderful new book
that I had a opportunity to read and
will listen to when it's out on
audiobook May 5th and we'll try to have
this up as well as links to your other
things where can people find out more
about you online and what's your next
project
well more about me online there is I
have a website which is Mario - leave
your comm not to be confused with a
website which I don't have conduct which
is called Mario Livio dot-com without
the dish that is written by a person
that I don't know it's the hole you just
drove a lot of traffic to that site
because people I don't want to see what
it is I'll save me the trouble it's not
worth visiting
so it's Mario - Leo it's my actual
website and my next project well I of
course started thinking about the next
book but I don't like to talk about this
before you know I I really know that
that's a book I won't do it I understand
and I'll remind people they can find dr.
Mario Livio at Mario - Olivia or Mario
underscore Livio on Twitter and he
tweets quite quite frequently and it's
always quite interesting to see his
pundit tree about all the issues of the
day and issues of many centuries ago in
the Galileo and the science deniers
Mario thank you so much it's been a real
treat as usual I hope we can see each
other in the coming months in person
thank you very much
and then I also too
[Music]
the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
you